the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so first up we're going to go around do
a couple things will just go in pairs
we'll try these out so you two can come
up first we will start off with one of
our basic principles of electromagnetism
which is that we can spin metal in a
magnetic field and produce current so
let's hook the hook up our little motor
to an LED and see if we can make our
motor into a dynamo okay so it works is
not easy but it works we're using a
motor in Reverse for spinning that on a
magnetic field and producing Sakura to
line up our led very good ok now let's
plug in this to our amplifiers and try
make sure we do our telharmonium light
so it's the turn of the century it's
around 1900 your Cahill and you're like
I need a way to produce sound I eat the
way to create an oscillator we need a
somewhat spastics if you're gonna count
but you can hear that if it were
spinning you know it's some concentrate
you get out there's moonlight has less
resistant
so let's continue this motorbike in a
tone that one is tighter but so you just
gets got a better person okay can it
work as a musical instrument when we
need to do matter what if you wanted to
make a little dough so much yeah I got
all these brands god moaning like a
[ __ ] tables ready okay next time okay
okay good so uh next up I like what are
you okay so you guys didn't work as a
team what you want to turn the butter
while they're going to critically the
strong letters just feel the mother
senior come on sense of time is really
try to click click you get a little bit
oh good so here is our humbucker to
single coils next to each other
essentially just a big rap of wire with
some little poles to focus the magnetic
energy now this design this is a nice
dimarzio pick up I was talking earlier
it's in pink I got the pink one because
it was cheaper think about the issues in
the old and then deeper than a black one
same performance anyways this model has
four conductors which allows us to
access each of the coil separately we're
going to run them in series and treat
them just as one pick up so we mean are
this is our grounds here and this is our
hot signal to read
the reverse polarity humbucking at the
home [ __ ] action works in both series
in parallel according to the dimarzio
O'Donnell that seems like if you ran
them in series of that reversing them
again you would just knock out okay so
you got it in now the first thing to try
is um putting turning our motor before
we get to the phone now what this device
is going to do is a pick up moving metal
that perturbs the magnetic field so if
we spin our motor in front of the pickup
let's see if we can get us out same
sound that's right we shouldn't be
surprising but it is still okay good now
what if we put a vibrating metal string
on top of this maybe we might pick up a
sound right let's try to hide okay hold
on okay so one of you has to be somebody
keys here has moved on the damper and
the other needs to yeah you're good
it has a high directionality maybe if we
do it for the direct line is very sore
today so it really matters with the
location
maybe let's turn off the distortion oh
yeah yeah okay it's writing it now just
move it hold on one note press that
window repeatedly and move to pick up to
the left and rice we can hear a focus to
pick up days of that
now if you rest it actually rested on
the keys good try to do some sort of
ebone today so we could try to do some
sort of evo thing where we direct the
acoustic energy out of the pickup on the
strings not out of that amp onto the
string all right now this is it going to
work great but the idea here is that
we're using the amplification to re
resonate the string and creating a
feedback loop in the process the dampers
actually if you rested on the keys your
buddy
nice now change the position of the
speaker of the midst of you
okay great good job guys good job move
on next up leave the pickup connected
and uh now we need some sort of devices
that give off electromagnetic radiation
we have a device gives awesome recently
wife singer ok so just right up let's
try the phone first alright let's see an
awesome but I'll just hold the phone
over the divisor we can move it around a
little bit so we're getting some moves
you're trying to ensure that i found
this bull you get the text just holding
slowly and move it whoa can we make this
into a musical sure if we put processes
through some delays and filters you can
get some really some really nice sounds
there we go now that's when it goes to
sleep I found that last night neat I
don't know exactly and the chirp is it's
periodically reading the accelerometer
and then I was easily measurement it
wakes up again there's the chippendale
apart oh really because the chips can
still sample really like you know once
every second or something they can take
a sample T so long so who know you have
a passive that's amazing that you can
hear that there's some side-channel
attacks just waiting to be exploited
good time
yeah that's like the ground noise okay
now have some fiber and yesterday here I
we have some special using the
vibrations of the of the phone let's try
these out before guess you might like
actually using this up the purple side
on the switch switch i sentence the
speakers are magnetic hey we actually
just act as a microphone if you just put
sound wow that's nice thank you is it
vibrate yes yeah that's giving us a kick
turn right there
okay so that works well oh nice we keep
squeezing it
you got a happy message okay now you
mentioned about what about speaker so
what is a what is it what is uh what is
a conventional acoustics speaker how
does it work coiled a magnet moving back
and forth so these things have speakers
in them right and if we play some music
like a little Afrika Bambaataa nose is
cute okay ah now great did you do I see
a photograph protege okay let's try to
see you can do some of that ah alright
so anybody want to guess red is maybe
hot um what's use let's try connecting
read to the positive which is yellow for
us and then let's try hooking up the
black where's that blue to this might be
a stereo benefits of Syria Syria
okay so let's see if we if you move the
needle do you hear anything so where is
it just right there yeah okay try the
white okay there we go there's something
there okay so the basic now see if you
can yes Oh boards of canada you don't
get a yes okay
you got if you want to be in the groove
so try to line it up a little something
there doesn't get to push hard okay the
basic will try to simulate a basic
principle of photograph video how does
it work coded language to learn that the
stylus is connected to a little metal
that's moving in a magnetic fields
exactly okay great we'll play without a
little bit more um I want you guys to
get started on building some oscillators
so so Collins in the great tradition of
hardware hacking has an approach for us
to build oscillators using a digital
chip that's not intended to be used as
an oscillator at all you guys will work
in pairs you can work with your neighbor
oh nice oh that's what I need what do
you trying to lose me i give it to you
is so ah colin has us use the hex
schmitt trigger which is a very simple
device which allows us to basically flip
and flop between a zero and one output
namely uh
a voltage allowing us to alter between
two voltages now what we're going to do
with this chip is we're simply going to
use pins one and two we're going to use
one of these little triggers and we're
going to heat it back into itself and
cause it to oscillate so now you all
have your chips in except for those of
you that don't have a chip so I can't
hear table sweaters breakout and like
get on ground and gunpowder ok cool got
to set up someone and then we need to do
what we need to eat it i want a nearly
want a feedback running to you want
sound out which component do you think
it is ok so the first thing we do is
provide power to our chip that's already
done on the boards that i gave you you
want to take that der these here when it
is orient the ground on the bottom make
an excellent city or in the ground on
the bottom and ok so you want it to look
like this hoarding the ground on the
bottom and connect as a sister between
any powers guide to the power of us and
the ground to the ground the bus yeah
absolutely and you guys need
I wanted to cab from what 12 ground I
think and then you've got sound around
now this was in terms of yeah exactly
this and that's the nice I r we go we
made some there yeah check the heat okay
wait for the okay ground good good and
then you got the resistor feeding back
into the second pin okay good you guys
need some components are basic
oscillator set up and let's hear what we
get so uh here's one day on first I
wanna go in there we go the beauty of
synthesis some stupid everybody's in its
everyone you try the same value
confronts oh nice long passages
very well resistance good okay no its
capacitance that's been for your fingers
would you have a parallel capacitor no
I'm I'm bypassing the resistor in my
nice okay good like a nightmare or
something this sounds awesome with
everybody obviously the next the next
I'm you a Tundra into heroin abuse is
happening yeah better i don't think i
understand i don't think at all sorry
injury oh yeah i don't know how much we
get reliable yeah you better go I don't
like the reunion or whether they would
even like
oh you can try to later
we did a good thing I love that ok just
swap it out hot swap it for the for the
speaker we're in crisis mode you got a
sound it's guys actually came out here
which means needed we got netflix let's
maybe slow it down and try the resistor
again but instead of so high you know
you said I tried the other one use a
beer faster gene masters you guys pause
for a sec yes ok pause for a sec we're
going to make sure these guys who are
doing ultimate acts with oh ok how big
is that yeah ok so this pot home let's
pause for a second ok now the reason
great has the lower tone to your nice
tone is because of different capacitor
is being used so the capacitor going
from k12 the ground by marrying that Pat
capacitor we can set a different
frequency range for the oscillation the
principal we're using it for oscillation
is feedback right we're taking the
output of pin to feeding it back in to
pin one which through the resistor that
is causing the 12 foot to 0 the 0 2 foot
21 and continually producing what kind
of sounds is it essential
something like a sawtooth where ish is
going from 1 to 0 but it's going to fall
so it's not going to be a straight
square wave but it's going to be
something square like everybody happy
with the first synthesizers a bit
pointless you yo-yo that attention so
you guys helicopter you David ok now we
can have a media fun by replacing our
resistor with the photoresistor the
photoresistor allows us very resistance
if we vary the resistance in the
feedback from pin 12 pin to what we be
able to do change the frequency of
oscillation so some of you have already
good I'm going to borrow the answer
minute ok yeah I'll do with the movie ok
oh oh it's ok you win distill you want a
g-string cannot direct the big black one
is ya tryin to smoke with that did it
work fun to notice again here's a 10
Christy singles I'm getting the basic
okay so what you got yes on try alia
okay caribou this around if you got the
speaker yet with your recently situation
is
I think families yeah I think we're not
maybe we go it's really slow with these
big happening to our pulses we got
incredible folsom so we're going to
we're going to us and the whole thing
flex light so you cover it all the way
mrs. like oh okay good okay
yes okay let's pause the cosmetologist
let's pause okay so you discovered with
the photoresistor we can vary the
frequency by swapping out different
capacitors we can get different
frequency ranges oh why don't you swap
out the new the big budget buster we
really want plus here we have a larger
capacitor which gives us a really nice
little frequency tones which I think are
leaving now to get even a more pleasing
tone what we're going to do is insert
the diode into the alkaloid which is a
hack that Collins uses and somebody can
explain to me why this sounds better but
it sounds nice when we stick a signal
through the diode so we're going to take
the output of pin to put it through the
diode and then pick up that output from
there and you the diode is erection oh
so you want to make sure I got it out
but yeah yeah well I get me just amend
on the flaring the whole thing yeah I
simply black industry
yeah okay so we're taking the signal
something too good of your videos hear
me it's a lot out of a quick created
using this cap missing my him right now
that no nothing everywhere let's hear
that now that's a nice turn
and if you cover it all around he's
actually sensitive all over yeah so
probably got a tiny little sausages I
know it sounds better with the diet I
directly
okay Oh actually 48 which are outputs in
you you guys are going to give some
crazy will be Evan ensemble okay that's
right turn that overdrive
oh you're jumping around all right I
guess no because you're just going to
shake you to the top half of the bottom
is this like big ones y'all set in this
witch
oh gee
oh yes
we have three
and this
Oh
oh he
Oh
Oh
okay pause all right now the last thing
we're going to do which amazing we have
time to try but we'll try to do a
Collins very simple low pass filter
circuit which is a total hack but all we
have to do is insert another resistor I
should a photo resistor and a capacitor
to the output I have to diagram for this
somewhere here this will give us with
another photo resistor are essential to
parameters which should help us yeah
I'll keep the diet in there so take the
output is daya and then and now or take
a photo resistor for resist bucks oh
it's not next one is a bachelor to
ground cut off like so we did another
cut so try the filter you need to be
going should do it turn it up a little
bit
the person so you're up all the way
we're having sab low pass filters
maybe if we when I touch it yeah you're
bridging it yeah okay it's time to make
some music we're going to do duets oh ok
so and you guys will be a trio yeah so
why don't we so with you guys you you
guys did you guys will go from the sides
and then we'll all we can do therefore
at the same time ok that's great ok
you're going to do an improvisation it's
going to be a minute or two minutes and
we're going to use a very simple
improvisation technique that works in
almost any context um you're still
crystal ok so know what we're going to
do is set up a basic astana T so you're
going to repeat some musical motive find
some little thing that you can repeat it
can be a little some little gesture
that's identifiable and repeat it and
keep on repeating it's like a drum
circle basically we're using our photo
resistor theremins to do in a drum
circle so I'll study you'll start off
you'll create a sort of pattern and then
hold it the next person will come in try
to do something that fits in with that
pattern after it's going then [ __ ] swap
the amps change the pattern Oh a little
bit and then it'll be done
Oh
sir
you guys you guys are coming down
there's a good ending opportunity there
you hear is ending abuse it it's good to
get out while you're ahead
you